genius brain listeners this podcast is
brought to you by better help mental
health is super important it has always
been important and guess what so are you
so if you're thinking about giving
therapy a try try it with better help
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and is suited to
your schedule all you have to do is fill
out a small questionnaire and you'll get
matched with the licensed therapist and
you can switch therapists at any time
for no additional charge because you
know much like everything in life
um you got to find the right fit for you
and that's what I really like about
Better Health find more balance with
Better Health visit betterhelp.com jeans
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better health.com genius
and because he didn't want to give half
to his wife he [__] kidnapped her hog
titer stabbed her in the chest buried
her in a shallow grave
drove away she's alive [__] crawls
the [__] out good Korea
she goes
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast I'm your host
David so and we got our reoccurring host
Ed Park my friends cheers
tears Cheers Cheers listen you guys have
been dming me about uh a topic that I
just don't care about anymore you guys
are saying like see Malu is at it again
and I just don't care it is the same
story over and over again I don't want
to repeat it yeah I don't even know what
it's about and I my life is completely
okay
whatever we said last time it's the same
thing over again
shout outs to semen Lube last time
bro yeah it's gotta be the last time
yeah dude freaking um holy [__] so I saw
uh Guardians of the Galaxy three was it
amazing yeah you know what it wasn't a
Disney Marvel film it was a James Gunn
film really yeah okay it's like
hard-line piece it's like Indiana Jones
Temple of Dune PG-13 it's like right on
the line of rated R really yeah dude I
um
I didn't watch it because it was just so
packed oh yeah it's gonna be packed
first so it's just like I always I'm
waiting till like the theater dies a
little bit because it stays bro
matinee I gotta go week weekday morning
times because [__] some of these
people when I watch the films they piss
me off they scream and yell yeah it's
just so annoying and it's like there's
always a guy in there that's trying to
insert a joke so people can laugh like
it's a stand-up comedy show and I just I
can't stand it it wasn't like that at
the arc like but the ArcLight doesn't
exist anymore right because so I watch
in Hollywood right so I'll go I used to
go to our Glide the Cinerama dump but
now I go to the tcl's Chinese Theater
and the fourth largest IMAX Green in
America apparently so the the thing is
though at ARC like and Cinerama and like
Al Capitan and then uh Chinese Theater
people who work in the industry in the
movies go to those theaters oh okay and
so they just like respect what the hell
is going on yeah and so like I was in a
theater and it was none of those other
Marvel
oh my God Cameo like all that [__] and I
think probably because like I said it
doesn't feel like a Marvel Disney film
it feels like a James Gunn film that
there wasn't those like cameos that made
you like blow your load I was watching
um Ant-Man and there was a gun so you
saw it there was a guy that screamed
this one joke and I felt so bad for him
because nobody nobody else left what was
the joke it wasn't
it wasn't even really a joke but who was
the the female lead
um well that's the problem with the
movie too because it's supposed to be
the WASP why yeah Evangeline Lily the
titular character who has nothing to do
in the movie is that her yeah so she
came out and he just goes oh yeah and
then Dead Silence God so he made it
wasn't a joke in the film he made a joke
he tried to make a joke and it was just
dead silent and I mean I feel that that
I also feel bad for eventually
nobody else thinks she's
oh yeah I just hear some dude in the
corner just go shut the [__] up
everybody busted up laughing oh man to
get one up like that he made a joke
nobody laughed and the guy that told me
shut the [__] up made the whole theater
laugh yeah I was like oh I hate this
silent did he stay silent yeah he didn't
make any more noise after that again doc
I [__] yeah sometimes it's hard with
like Marvel films because of that type
of [__] but I definitely want to watch
guards of the Galaxy the first one was
[__] amazing yeah it was so damn good
especially because nobody expected
anything from it I didn't know anything
about the comic book oh yeah
and I think that's why they kind of
allowed so much free reign with it to do
whatever because nobody had expectations
yeah and then we can accept what we're
seeing as we saw it yeah and I once
you've seen Guardians 3 then we could
probably talk about the entire Trilogy
at once I watch I'll watch it this week
because yeah I mean I definitely
if if you do watch it I do want to do a
review of suzume so I gotta catch that
one too yeah like that movie was so good
I watched it twice and this is a pretty
long film it actually did over 300
million dollars oh out in Asia oh damn
300 billion I better catch that before
it leaves theater too because I know
it's not it's probably not doing too
well here right yeah I think I think
opening week here did like two mil right
but overall oversees everything in total
I looked at the number the other day it
was over 300 million dude I was shocked
but then uh you were saying it's the
same people who made your name yes yeah
okay I mean so if you've seen your name
you know like oh I gotta see this right
yeah I mean just 2D animation if you
guys don't watch 2D animation films
because you are kind of bought into just
3D alone 2D animation film is in like
another category of itself and it can
never be replaced it's his own art it's
completely its own art and you know for
me
obviously I have like an affinity
towards you know
uh like Spirited Away and you know like
but this director does something very
unique and you know your name was
amazing too yeah but damn watching this
it's been a while since I've watched the
2D animation film and I got completely
lost in it and then that two hours felt
like that yeah for me when as I watched
your name I felt like why is this
animated yeah yeah like a lot of that's
the crazy thing about animation in Japan
is that the art is so I don't know if
revered is the right word but then it is
the medium that people draw towards that
they can make they can have these real
like human the human scripts but just
make an animated it's like why don't
they just get real people to do this
like yeah okay but and it's funny
because a lot of people kind of take the
the film composition from 2D animation
and they apply it to real life film yeah
yeah yeah because of how first of all
like even the way that they they draw
things right it's too deep but they pay
a lot of attention to lighting right and
it blows my [__] mind I'm like damn
this is amazing I I really wish somebody
could translate this into film is what I
keep on thinking right because if they
could then I'm pretty sure this I think
your name is pretty primed for a live
action you know take it could be
Hawaiian so it could be in English right
because not exactly like Asian American
story I don't know how because we
haven't been here that long yeah dude
when's the last time you went to a
graduation
oh man it's been a minute so I I went to
a graduation okay first of all
I in general don't like formal events
right formal events makes my balls itch
yeah I [__] hate formal events it's
hard enough for me to sit or sit down at
church and that's for a part of my
salvation you know
you know I can't Church weddings and
then what is this you went to again
graduation a graduation and Court yes
the weddings is so hard for me and you
know I've already said on this podcast
in a million times I [__] hate
weddings it's not like yeah there's the
idea of weddings or whatever but I
understand why people enjoy it right
you're celebrating your family your
friends your parents love this it's a
joyous occasion I just I can't sit still
I [__] hate it right you know is it
also that do people come up to you with
a microphone like hey do something say
something funny let me tell you this
dude
so there was a wedding that I went to
and I so this person asked me to do a
speech at their wedding right because
they know who I am
I told them ahead of time I'm here for
fun I'm here to get [__] drunk and
act the fool that's it I don't want to
do any work [__] I'm not doing a speech
whatever this is what I do for a living
they said okay I got it
so we're sitting at the table and during
this time you know there's the best man
speech there's the uh what do you call
that person not the bridesmaid is it
made of honor the maid of honor speech
they did that right and apparently there
was like a 15-minute down time
and this person goes up and I've already
expressed this person I don't want to
talk and they're like okay uh we have
some time does anybody else want to come
up and say something oh my God and you
could tell that she was referring to me
all right and then I'm sure every other
eyeballs were looking at you and if you
looked at my face it was irritated I'm
just like this
and then people at my table they're just
like just do it like it's already
awkward just [__] do it
and I and I warned her I was like I
don't want to do this so I go up and for
10 minutes I just [__] roast her ass
for [__] 10 to 15 minutes straight oh
God people were dying laughing it was
literally like Anthony Jeselnik type of
roast dude I was [__] going you're
just going in on her because she has a
lot of weird weird a lot of people love
her but a lot of people dislike certain
things about it that everybody knows
about so I just was like that you know
so I pointed everything on that nobody
else will talk about exactly so people
were dying and then after the whole
thing she goes wow you really went in on
me I was like I [__] told you I don't
want to do a speech so this is what you
got you know how they have the uh the
the wrap-up video of their wedding and
[__] and they have all the speeches
guess whose part was taken out
my speech was
of course man [__] annoying man I
hate that [__] so I went to a graduation
this week
and um it's my best friend's uh younger
sister Tony so she's graduating with the
Masters and
one of the most awkward things happened
dog I I I cannot tell you how much in
Goosebumps I got from how [__] corny
this [__] was not from what she did so
this girl was going up and she was
giving her speech because she was
getting her Masters right so I guess
everybody oh actually I think this one
she was getting her doctorate so
everybody who was getting their doctor
was giving a speech
and of course
have you ever met somebody who went up
on stage it's like these people who are
like okay oh I don't want to do this but
I guess I'll do it
but it's been planned yeah so she goes
up and then she starts giving her speech
she comes out and she goes um
a lot of people have asked me to sing oh
no
people have asked me to sing and they're
like I bet you're not gonna sing and I
said you know what since you said that I
am going to sing
[Applause]
was cringing so hard she could have just
started singing
they never
know what I'm not sure
have you ever met that person that just
takes these moments and like this is my
time yeah to shine but they wanted to do
it as like fake humble as possible yeah
and so she goes you know a lot of people
said I had just you know are you gonna
sing I was like I'm not gonna sing and
they challenge me so I'm gonna sing I
don't care I'm just gonna [__] do it
and then she just starts belting a whole
[__] song oh man in the middle of her
speech I'm just like dude acapella
acapella
I wanted scores that [__] was so hard to
sit through yeah just like you know it's
just I can't do it I can't do it I just
do it and uh
cycling does anybody have any alcohol
listen I'm growing tomatoes right now I
wish one of them was ripe so I could
think of tomatoes
[Laughter]
I was embarrassed for her I don't
understand why people this actually
happened during my um
my high school reunion right there was a
girl
who uh she was a part of the student
body and they're obviously the ones that
put everything together and she goes up
on stage and she goes uh does anybody
know the High School alma mater this who
knows it somebody should come up and see
it somebody could come up and sing it
nobody knows it of course nobody she
goes I I think I remember it oh oh here
we go come on sing along if you know it
[__] she did an r b version oh nice
dog brunette
hello I was like first of all you
practice this a hundred percent in front
of the mirror in front of the mirror
nobody knows or remembers our High
School alma mater are you out of your
[__] mind especially my school we had
no school spirit oh same same at all
dude I my
uh freshman class there were 400
students my graduating class was 88.
God damn yeah so I went to like you know
I I keep saying I went to the school in
the sticks like those people don't give
a [__] either about their education like
they'll be like why why am I going to
school and just go work him yeah you
know the factory or at the shipyard or
at this as a mechanic or as a this and
that and then yeah a bunch of kids just
think High School is pointless out there
there's a lot of people in high school
who like
I'm not talking about my my friend
specifically but I've definitely seen
people who I've seen on online through
like Facebook where I look at them and
I'm like [__] man time beat the [__] out
of you all right like they look way
older than they should it kind of blows
my mind and there's like some people too
where I'm like I remember you were kind
of hot are they White
so it's just you know what I figured out
too A lot of people who don't kind of
maybe it's also because I'm from a
smaller town that once they kind of get
married and they have kids
they don't have like their own
aspiration aspirations and they're not
striving for anything aside from
obviously it's great that they're
focusing on their family right but the
identity is found in their family in
their family so they don't have their
own idea they don't keep up with like
either whether it's clothing style
fashion haircuts whatever the [__] that
it is yeah but like see I remember at
the beginning somebody who came up to me
like bro you look just like you did in
high school I'm like not you stress-free
brother
what the [__] happened to you it's crazy
watching like people melt in front of
your eyes I mean I got invited to my
20-year High School Reunion yeah and I
sent you that screenshot oh
those who people are talking about oh we
missed because we didn't have a 10-year
anniversary right so people found each
other on Facebook and then they were
like what's where's everyone been it's
people were like dead honest about their
meth addiction
well a lot of time has passed it must
have been though all those years of math
[Laughter]
I'm going though I'm gonna go and the
only car I have out there is the Miata
no it's not gonna roll up to my 20 year
anniversary in a pink Miata
there's so many people who I've seen
like
like a lot of high school sweethearts
and people who got married like they got
divorced and you kind of look at I'm not
saying that people who are divorced and
miserable right but there's some people
who just don't take it very well yeah
and you could tell by like the profile
picture and like they're they got this
old apartment and the carpet's all
stained I'm like bro what the forest
the divorced man they all have the same
selfie yeah
the same disgusting low and low angle
like tension
selfie yeah
it's like everyone's got the same
[__] face it's a dude I [__] saw
this oh [__] my buddy sent me this
article today
um out of nowhere and he was just like
bro you gotta watch this [__] video
there was a lady and uh I don't remember
this ever coming out but there was a
lady who was uh going around because she
created this children's book or her her
husband who passed away and she kind of
blew up on it because uh she created a
children's book for uh for her kids to
cope with her father's death saying like
even though Daddy's dead
um he's still here for us right and it
was super sweet she was on TV and
everything right
it turns out she [__] murdered him
bro
[Music]
they did a [__] investigation and
they found out that she poisoned him
oh God like over a long period of Time
how [__] insane do you have to be to
[__] murder your husband then Prophet
office of his death and then create a
children's book for your kid dude that's
gone girl yes
[Laughter]
crazy
here's some crazy so how they found out
I mean obviously there's um like there's
personal accounts right so her husband
before he passed away talked to his
family and said hey look if I ever die
my wife did it he said that to his
family and before his death
they say this all in this one news
article before his death apparently he
they went out to like for like a
Valentine's dinner
and he felt really sick like he was
going to die but he survived obviously I
don't know how yeah but he was telling
his best friend like listen I think
that she tried to poison me that she
could that she was trying to poison and
kill me and it turns out she actually
[__] did first of all from the first
time that she tried that [__] you should
have left yeah
oh
[Laughter]
yeah so the guy
apparently she tried to poison him once
it didn't [__] work out right and
then um there was like either voicemails
or there was like accounts of her trying
to get drugs like like a ridiculous
amount of fentanyl yeah
her life that she said to the drug
dealer was give me the good [__] that
the Michael Jackson stuff
genius brain listeners this podcast is
brought to you by better help with me
David so listen if you guys are thinking
about focusing on your mental health
this year start with better help it's
something that I personally love I have
used better help for uh you know finding
the therapist and for therapy for quite
a while now which is why they've been
sponsoring this podcast for a hot second
I do use better help uh and for those of
you out there that haven't tried uh
talking to a therapist give a better
help a try because if you're thinking
about starting it why not start now it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule all you have to do is uh fill
out a brief questionnaire and you'll get
matched with a licensed therapist and
switch therapists at any time for no
additional charge and I got to tell you
something it's super quick and easy and
I I really do enjoy it and for a lot of
us out there we think that hanging out
and maybe talking to some people that we
know is therapy but those things can be
very therapeutic which is great but
therapy tends to hit a little different
so give it a try this year find more
balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com genius today to get 10
off your first month that's
betterhealthheop.com genius
yikes the Michael Jackson type of drugs
yikes and so this detective apparently
was saying like when it comes to
um people who poison their spouses or
try to murder their spouses it's almost
never a story where they don't leave a
ridiculous amount of breadcrumbs to find
out because she didn't [__] it she did
the worst [__] job ever yeah she
actually tried oh she actually
um
uh inserted herself as a sole
beneficiary to his will before he died
right but her husband found out and then
took took her off
so she didn't get anything and so she
wrote a children's book that's what I'm
saying this is [__] the craziest
story I ever heard in my life like dudes
dead and she's like I'm gonna get you
[__]
first of all once somebody tries to
poison me I'm out
why the [__] did he go back and then eat
another meal from her I don't understand
that [__]
I mean I'm a victim blamer yeah
I'm only saying it from my perspective
as a man if I ate one of like let's say
Mariel
we were going through these whole fights
I found out that she put me as a sole
beneficiary and then suddenly my stomach
was hurting I didn't feel good I thought
I was going to die I had to go to poison
control taste like [__] Tide Pods
yeah like I somehow survive it I'm never
eating another meal with that person
ever again yeah yeah ever yeah I've been
there where someone cooked for me and
then I had to go to the ER
oh you yeah I had to go to the [__]
ER after someone made a meal for me
uh it was supposed to be some healthy
[__] that he was starting and then I
just remember waking up at like three or
four in the morning and so much [__]
pain right and then I called my my uh
brother because he was working in uh in
a hospital at the time and I was like
what do I do he was like just wait it
out until you just can't feel like you
can't do anything just go to the
emergency room I saw it like six or
seven a.m I went to the ER
and then um when I got in there and put
me in there and then the doctor it was
just korean-american dude
chicken only passing my stomach and he's
like hey bro I think you're just like
really backed up right it's like I'm
gonna give you some laxatives
so I had the soda this little jelly cup
and this other like shot of something
and I sat there and it was like 20
minutes past but the pain in my stomach
ceased so I was like hey I think I'm
gonna go home right and he goes oh are
you sure and I'm like yeah I don't feel
anything anymore it's like okay well you
know you just go go straight home okay
and I'm like all right and then the next
thing I know I'm [__] lost in this
hospital because I've never been there
before yeah and I start feeling it the
lacks it is coming and now I'm just I'm
not even trying to go home I'm trying to
find a bathroom yeah and I unloaded like
[__] crazy then I go home and then I
just all [__] day just [__] was
[__] right and there's no [__]
way I'm ever gonna eat another meal from
them again
you know yeah I don't know if you really
suspected someone's trying to kill you
that sounds worse than food poisoning
yeah and this guy decided to eat another
[__] meal
I'm sorry we are are we victim blaming
oh the man died the man died okay hey
rest in peace what the [__] man what the
[__] I I don't I just would never try to
eat another meal from that [__]
person ever again it doesn't make sense
to me but this lady is pretty [__]
psychotic man yeah I mean I'm glad they
caught her and first of all too like
when I when I started doing this
detective just going off about how many
different ways they've caught her and
like the evidence was ridiculous it's
just like she didn't even leave a
[__] email.com yeah she'd even leave
like breadcrumbs she just built the
whole Bakery and just had everybody come
in and take some bread out search
history just like Craigslist poison my
husband
there was that one person who actually
did that well it wasn't it wasn't a girl
but it was a I think it was a husband
where he was like trying to figure out
how to murder his wife yeah and they
just looked at his Google search it was
how to get it how to get away with
murder
[Laughter]
it's like actually actually kill
somebody
I am not Viola Davis
it's like how to get rid of a body and
not get caught he was like typing
ridiculous [__] dude so back I was in
Washington
and uh Dan came up for a week to see his
parents and I met up with him and we
went to a Mariners game
and he was like
dude have you heard of
the Korean lady who was like stabbed and
buried alive
but survived I'm like what the [__]
knows like apparently it was all over
the news in the northwest
she was like she's the receptionist at
our church what yeah and he's like my
mom and dad told me they're like yeah
this happened yeah like this
lady uh wanted a divorce from her
husband and he is like a 30-year veteran
you know and so he's got pension and all
that which he then now has to give up
because he's retiring you know and
because he didn't want to give half to
his wife he [__] kidnapped her hog
titer
stabbed her in the chest buried her in a
shallow grave
drove away she's alive [__] crawls
the [__] out dude
but yes you're [__] climbed out of
the Grave [__] ran to the nearest
house in hysterics apparently you know
you see a dirty half buried like duct
taped woman with a stack with a pumma
yeah probably
with a robin hair yeah
just somebody help me yeah dude like
what the f how did she start first of
all how did she survive you suck at
stabbing bro you're in the military
yeah I mean I thought he would kill her
I mean first of all
he would either if she died he still
would have gotten caught yeah 100 he
would have gotten caught it was just
such a maniac move like so she's like is
he Korean nope yeah he's Korean too he's
Korean in the American Military
because I know so they're like in their
50s 60s yeah they're older like Korean
people yeah what the [__] because I know
in that area there's a lot of like
Korean people who um marry outside of
their ethnicity yeah because Fort Lewis
is the military base that everyone in
America gets stationed to Korea that's
where they go first they get all their
training there and then about Korean
whatever if they have to then they're in
Korea for however many years and then
they debrief back at Fort Lewis and then
they either come back with their Korean
wives or go looking for a Korean women
in Tacoma so there's a lot of have like
Koreans there our mayor is half black
half Korean I wonder if like like the
Sunday after she went back to being a
receptionist she did
did you just saved me
this is my side she's going to heaven
for sure
yeah she went back up the receptionist
in the office she wasn't on like on the
brink of death he must have missed like
all the vital organs did I guess she he
stabbed her once and she just survived
it I don't know and she like passed out
from the pain or something and something
and he thought she was dead I think the
story is that he buried her alive but it
was she just survived it this will just
put like one scoop of dirt on her yeah
it's the most half-assed like murder
ever
but one school but she's like yeah
what if she's like the most annoying
person ever to the point where he
stabbed her and she just kept talking
[__] he goes you know what I don't care
anymore
all right just catch me all right
she's probably getting 100 now okay he's
in jail oh yeah oh no yeah I mean I
don't I think he was already retired but
if he wasn't then he's military prison
is another thing right oh yeah I didn't
even think about that um
what they have kids too then for sure I
think so for sure yeah they'll go to the
church how awkward
wait how is she how does she go back to
being a receptionist the next day after
she got stabbed in the chest I don't
know some people have this resolve like
um the there's a uh bar and grill across
the street from my gas station my mom
went to the store like 10 minutes late
one day right but when she pulled up the
bar and grill was all like
like uh police line all of that [__] and
like ambulance and cops and then the
owner got shot that morning that early
morning some guy looking for alcohol
just came in and if in the video cameras
he came to our store first and it was
closed because my mom was late and then
he went to the bar and grill
it's like and then he shot the [__]
owner but he lived and then he came back
to work
the next [__] day
where did he get shot like right around
here I guess it just went right through
him and he just he just had this resolve
like welcome welcome to Kim's
Convenience
I know gun survivor he's a big Burly
white dude oh is he yeah oh my God he's
just he got shot and then he just showed
up the next day but then he was really
he was really chewing on that [__]
because he even came by ourselves he
never comes by our store never seen him
I've just seen him in the newspaper and
he just kind of came in just to show up
for me to be like hey I heard your gut
and then he wanted the congratulations
and stuff
[Music]
it was good for his business people
started flocking to his restaurant to
support him really yeah that's the best
thing that ever happened to you dude
that's pretty [__] amazing yeah what
a lazy Korean man though dude you always
got here once and then you just put one
scoop of dirt on her what is she a seed
or are you trying to [__] say
germinate her dog so who's Now gardening
references I'm not happy that she didn't
die at all I'm not saying that I went
straight back the following Sunday
did I I sometimes wonder too like
what what causes P you could always just
oh divorce he didn't want to give the
money away the money away yeah which is
30 years plus in the military that
pension is probably a lot
oh my God I mean a lot of people do I
mean I feel like it's also shame too
because in the Korean Community when you
get a [__] divorce your from your
social Pariah yeah yeah yeah like you're
you're untouchable like who's gonna ever
marry you ever again it's like in that
age too exactly yeah I mean there was a
China name that or that happened at our
church Apparently one of the elders was
fooling around with some like younger
younger girl like a 20-some-year-old
Korean girl from Korea
and
he divorced his wife
went off with her and then they just
went to another church down the street
why are why are people so lazy yeah when
they do something wrong yeah dude I mean
like some people just do not give a [__]
especially if it doesn't give a [__] if
it's church either you know who speaking
up here you know [__] Robert De Niro
just hadn't had a kid just just had a
kid he's [__] 79. he had a kid
recently with who with with his younger
wife I think she's Asian uh 79 he busted
[__] nuts and this is like seventh or
eighth kid damn oh I guess Clint
Eastwood was doing that too right oh was
he yeah like Clint Eastwood's oldest
he's pushing 90 and he had kid in his
60s how the [__] does your sport but
this is him at 79 79 that's [__]
crazy how the [__] do you how the [__]
is he still getting it up Viagra oh
that's right yeah that's right that's
right Bluetooth all sorts of gas station
pills I don't understand though like
listen I I'm not denying that maybe
they're in love right yeah but what it's
like a 40-year age difference and
everybody knows this that once you reach
a certain age your breath just smells
different dude your 10 year old kid will
not recognize you 100 that's all he's
gonna be 89. 89 but literally how many
years left till you know you might only
have three four years left who knows who
knows unless he's doing that you know
rich people Hollywood [__] with people's
blood or some [__] right people's breath
smells different
I remember just like my parents were
getting old I'm like oh they got old
people breath like it literally smells
like death like well I guess that issue
comes from like the fact that all people
lose their sense of smell when they get
older and so they don't know what they
smell like
so they just have that must yeah and
like the crappy thing is it's like
because they're getting old for some
reason they like to talk closer to you
it smells so bad sometimes you're
burning my eyebrows off so that's what
my dad talks about like as he's talking
I just put like a piece of gum in his
mouth like please Jesus Christ man
you're [__] just the Korean word for
halitosis I have no idea about halitosis
so but you're speaking in tongues
my parents actually just landed in uh
Korea today
and it's so weird like
that whole process of getting them to
Korea was a [__] headache but now
that they're there I think my parents
are very happy that their parent their
kids got to you know buy them a ticket
too great or something like that and
they're sending me photos of them like
on the plane and everything else and I
kind of like today when I looked at it I
was kind of happy for them it's weird
watching my parents get to experience
things later in life that they never got
to experience when they were younger
especially because you know we obviously
were struggling we're super poor they
had to worry about paying for our
College you know finances or whatever
but now that they're at the later years
in life and they're probably going to
retire real soon it's it's weird
watching my parents experience something
that I feel that most people should
experience you know what I'm saying but
they they definitely like seeing them in
like the business class tickets that I
bought them was trippy to me yeah I'm
like oh look at them I'm like you could
tell my dad is enjoying it like every
little food that came out this food took
a photo sentence he had like that they
made send it to me he was in the
business class Lounge I've seen lamel
before okay and he didn't even send me a
photo of the shitla did but it was ready
it was a soup
I just ate it yeah but dude it's like my
dad like they've never been in uh
business class tickets before and I
still remember when I first bought
business class tickets and uh it was
such a Trippy experience because like
people are coming up to you asking you
for things and you know giving you all
this like I'm not used to that [__] I'm
usually I'm used to [__] coach
tickets where they treat you like [__]
and you mind your own business exactly
but yeah just like watching them like
I'm I'm so happy that they get to do
something because my mom said too like
this is probably her last time that
she's gonna go to Korea before she dies
you know which I don't know why
grandparents parents love to make
everything so [__] sad you know why
because you're gonna be like well I'm
gonna buy you another ticket next year
but she said that she goes I'm so glad
I'm going to Korea this was probably the
last time I'm gonna see my family's
family members before I die melodramatic
and [__] yeah why do you like to ruin
good things
why did you say it like that yeah you
didn't have to say that my family would
be like that yeah like oh it's only a
matter of time before I die or whatever
it's like you've been saying that since
you were 60 you're 89 now your grandma's
89 yeah so you know I I visited her the
other day and then her hair she has a
full head of black hair and then I just
had to keep looking at it like what the
heck and then I could see the white at
the roots a little bit you know oh
because she dyed it yeah well she's even
lucky she has hair most people wear wigs
at that point right did they yeah
because their hair starts to fall off
um damn she still has a full head of
hair yeah it's palmed but yeah she's got
hair that's [__] crazy dude that's a
blessing yeah my grandma at like 93
still had black hair
my my mom's mom like
to the day she died she had black hair
like what the [__] the Yoda Harmony
that's what I mean [__] Bobby Lee I
think she just like is in her own world
without the kind of stress like that
ever affects her ever
I can't even imagine like I sometimes I
want I wonder what I'm gonna be like
when I'm a lot older and I and I do want
to be healthy right enough if I get to
an age where I can't even choose steak
just kill me just [__] add me right
now yeah I can't I can't live like that
I've seen people who have aged really
poorly and I just don't want to be like
that yeah you know what I mean I want to
be healthy enough to where I'm older
right or where I'm still relatively
cognizant I mean obviously I'll have
like death breath but you know like all
old people do
man like my dad when he turned 40 just
like gave up
gave up on life and he died at 53. Doc
like we said this before but when I saw
your dad I thought he was a grandpa yeah
which is crazy what like drugs do to you
yeah he was like yeah doing like drugs
and like just doing whatever the [__]
you wanted because when he turned 40 he
wouldn't see a doctor obviously a Korean
doctor and that Korean doctor like
[__] shamed the [__] out of him for
his health you know
um because he was a smoker and he didn't
exercise
and then he screamed at him like if you
don't do anything about your life and I
guess my dad was diabetic too he was
just like the green doctor scolded him
screened at him
I'm actually kind of shook right now I
didn't know your dad was 53. when he
died yeah and so he just went wild
towards the end of his life 53 bro I
thought your dad was like in his 70s
yeah yeah every time like I would keep
seeing him he would just keep withering
away but he was just not taking care of
himself he didn't give a [__] anymore
dog [__] meth is nuts
yeah did he continue to do that even
when before he passed away yes so like
he had this
Health scare where I think he like
passed out at the store right and so he
was at the ER and
um I drove over from Seattle it's like a
three and a half hour drive you know
that's how far are we away our store is
and then I go into the ER and I see him
and then the doctor comes up to me he's
like so you know he has like heart
disease and he's diabetic I'm sure you
know that I'm like yeah yeah
and he also has amphetamines in his
system
and in my head amphetamines I was
thinking about like Tylenol
yeah I didn't process because I was only
like
22 at the time or something
and so infinity and I was thinking about
it like oh the [__] he went to prison
for yeah yeah like he was still messing
with that you know
so he never kicked it never kicked it I
think he developed it in prison he I
don't think he was like that before he
went to prison after he went he came
back and all of that the symptoms of
being a meth addict came about addiction
is crazy because
um
I definitely
like for me obviously like I have a
weird Affinity towards food right like
food addiction is obviously hard enough
in and of itself right like carbon dish
and sugar addiction yeah and
I didn't realize okay I I had this weird
I love watching fat people shows like
that [__] makes me laugh so hard like
biggest losers yes yeah it makes me
laugh it makes me sad it also makes me
laugh and I could say I used to be
really big too and it only reminds me of
myself but they're like a worse version
of myself right
there was this video of this girl
who was crying because she couldn't eat
a Snicker and I died laughing because I
was like that's that hard I just
couldn't I can't fathom crying because
somebody wouldn't let me have my like
15th Snicker of the day right you know
it was like you have all the free Subway
you can eat this girl was like what am I
supposed to do
okay just just get my Snicker I'm so hot
well if I can't have a Snicker what am I
supposed to do what do you mean what are
you supposed to do yeah dude it's like
it's it's like her identity is tied to a
[__] Snicker bar or her hunger
response like I I used to watch this um
it was big it was this other show but
basically it was a doctor series on this
guy who was so fat he had to get cut out
of his [__] building my like thousand
pound life or something yeah yeah yeah
yeah TLC or something they had to bring
in a crane yeah bust the brick wall
because he's never left his bed in years
right in years right and his mom is also
who's really big was feeding him
constantly and they showed how much he
was eating he would eat
I think it was like four packs of bacon
for breakfast alone gosh a whole just
loaf of sliced bread like two dozens
it's not even like they're balling right
it's all credit card debt it's all like
critical EBT [__] or whatever yeah
because he's on disability right right
that's his breakfast and it reminded me
of this guy uh that I knew in high
school right so when you're big
there's like a certain amount of shame
to it right
um I never was okay I never was ashamed
because I was delusional but sometimes I
would get so irritated when people who
are fatter than me would pretend like
they're full yeah when I've seen what
they would eat right so there was a guy
who's a friend he's not that close to me
but he's a he's a friend of my friend
and every time we would go out to eat we
would go drinking or whatever I'm
talking about we would eat a burger
right he would eat half of it and this
gigantic [__] would just pretend like oh
he's a dainty dude bro he would eat half
the burger
and he was just like damn I'm so stuffed
I can't have I can't eat anymore
she's my guy
I ate two burgers and I'm still hungry
yeah and I'm half your size and he goes
I'm stuffed
just like I'm stuffed yeah once you have
a [__] senzu Bean like what the [__]
are you talking about he would
consistently and I just would never see
him eat Allah I don't understand why I
keep getting wet I don't eat a lot and
I'm like hmm what's the but what is the
projection to the fellas why is a guy
doing this to the dudes yeah I just
don't really care about that [__] and
bite you like as he's doing this I'm a
fat guy I'm like bro you're making me
look bad
I just ate two burgers and three fries
it's like clearly when you get home
there's like you know a dozen cupcakes
under your bed or some [__] so one day
it was a Cinco de Mayo right and we're
at this uh the spot it's like this
Cantina spot
um and we got [__] smashed this fool
drank a whole pitch of beer to himself
in one sitting and he drank a whole
bunch of other [__] I can't remember it
so it's it's from a while back he gets
[__] drunk and then we're like okay
let's go eat we went to go eat at a spot
called ops original Paris it's closed
now but it was like the diner spot that
even my cousin who's like in his 40s
went to
so we go to Ops right and now he's drunk
he his inhibitions are all gone his
walls are dead he doesn't have to
[__] fake it so I finally got to see
how much he ate yeah for the first
[__] time
I can't remember exactly what it was but
I'm trying to recollect what I said it
was something along the lines of like it
was three different dishes I remember he
had the like the pork loin meal because
that's the thing that's my favorite and
he had this other he had a second meal
which was their version of like the
Denny's Superbird
so but their thing is it's a it's a
trucker Diner yeah
ate that big biscuits and gravy like a
milkshake and then an appetizer oh God
and like hot chocolate just for himself
just for his [__] self that alone had
to be close to 6 000 calories yeah and
he ate that [__] like it was a [__]
Crouton on a salad yeah it's just
never-ending like garbage disposal
that's how you eat yeah that's that's
why you're fat so when whatever he said
to it I don't understand why I'm so fat
I'd [__] know dude no way it seems
like then he is I mean I'm I'm saying
this because I used to be 100 pounds too
for those of you guys listen yeah
um yeah that's right not just 100 pounds
um like I was pushing 240 250 and it
sounds like he's just ashamed of the way
he eats so in public and all that that
he has to project the way that
that he you know he's doing right yeah
but then I think a lot of people should
just understand like we get it we see
the evidence in front of us yeah it's
like if you keep rolling bro yeah also
just lie a little bit better if the guy
in front of you is half your size and
he's fat and he ate two burgers you
can't eat half a burger and say my word
I'm stuffed and have everybody believe
it dude yeah you should have ate two and
a half burgers and then be like damn I'm
full then maybe I'd [__] believe it I
can understand how it makes other people
feel fatter yeah and then like not so
good way because you know when I was on
my fasting kick
um I would still be social but so I
would go out but I wouldn't eat or drink
yeah right and so I'd go out with a
group of friends to a diner and then I
wouldn't order anything but water ice
water and then they were like dude
Edward like you're making us feel bad
and I couldn't understand I actually
argued with him I was like what are you
talking about I'm not eating because I
choose not to eat yeah you should eat
because you want to eat because you're
hungry I'm not stopping you from doing
it and they're like but us watching you
not eat makes us feel fat
sounds like a you problem bro yeah so I
was like oh I guess I shouldn't come out
anymore yeah so like socially I had to
like figure out what time I can eat and
change my like fasting schedule to eat
with people I'll tell you this man there
for anybody out there who listen I'm
still big right I actually gained just
10 pounds recently because I had an
injury and I ate the same amount but I
stopped working out
I'm getting hungry right now but
if you're a big person right and you
feel like ashamed of the way that you
look this is not going to be a speech
about change what you don't like about
yourself in case you didn't notice
we all know you're fat yeah whether
whether you [__] liked like you know
it or not we know you're [__] fat and
I told there's this kid who we went on I
went on a hike with
um I didn't go on a hike with him but I
was on a hike I did the Eaton Canyon
hike where there was a waterfall yeah
and there was a kid who uh
is a fan of mine and I took my shirt off
and I went down and I went to the
waterfall and I came back out
I think it comes up he goes hey so I'm a
big fan and he goes oh that [__] looks
[__] refreshing as [__] like I was
like like that looks [__] fun as hell
I was like yeah go in the water he goes
nah I can't do it because he was a
bigger guy I could tell he's ashamed of
the way he looks because he's wearing
literally all black black socks black
shoes black short black shirt no Shadows
so you don't have any underboobs yeah I
was like this guy looks like he's about
to [__] bartend tonight you know he's
on a hike and I'm looking at him and I
just go oh just going through the
[__] water it's dope he goes nah I
can't do that I want to take off my
shirt or nothing like that I looked at
this guy and I just talked to him I said
hey
you are you going to stop doing what you
want to do because you're afraid that
people
are gonna judge the way that you look I
was like whether you have that shirt on
or not we know you're [__] fat the
only [__] difference is that you're
not going to experience something that
you want to experience because you're
afraid of what people think and they're
not going to give a [__] about you yeah
they're gonna look at you once and
they're not going to remember you again
so this moment that you want you should
go and [__] experience it yeah and I
told this flaws like you know if you
have a shirt on and you go into that
water it's ten times worse it's a wet
t-shirt contest now
like just [__] take off your shirt
and go into the [__] waterfall and
then come out and put on a dry shirt
exactly it's like [__] it he took off
his shirt he went to the [__]
waterfall he enjoyed it came back out I
was like yo how's that feel he goes it
feels [__] good I'm like there you go
don't [__] worry about that [__]
nobody gives a [__] about you like that
everybody thinks people care about them
so much you're not that special I think
it's because when people hear you say
you are fat
people hear us saying you are ugly
people hear you're fat and they hear
you're worthless yeah I think that's the
problem and that people have to separate
from their identity that way and that's
something I had to do is one of those
things I had to take a good look at
myself and be like I know I'm not ugly
you know I'm fat that's all that's going
on like I know I have value and worth
I'm just fat you know and I separate
that from myself yeah you know although
I I'm gonna be completely honest I did
uh verbally abuse myself you know as I'm
fasting I told you you know I'd grab my
tits and I'd be like you fat [__]
[__] yeah you're so hungry
there's enough energy like right here
yeah I just you know like verbally abuse
myself and then allow myself to be
disciplined to fast through I want a
Denny's [__] club sandwich so bad
right now oh man you know we're going to
Denny's after this 100
as I was talking about my friend who
overeats I'm like damn he got the
[__] right recipe to life I want all
that food right now now I gotta go eat
yeah yeah oh [__] uh where are we at
we're at 52. oh [__] well guys that
wraps up this episode of The Genius
brain podcast if you're a fat boy enjoy
your life all right or if you want to
lose it go [__] lose it but don't
stop living life because you're afraid
of what people are going to think also
don't kill your husband yeah
holy [__]
huh do a little better bro I thought you
were in the military yeah well guys you
could catch Ed at edpark VP genius brain
every Sundays at 12 p.m uh the
pre-orders now when this goes up is is
done for the genius brain shirts I
believe or it's going to be the last day
that you can order it so uh get on that
because last time people just uh they
were like there's no more shirts because
it's pre-orders there's no stock of it
at all
um g-spring every Sunday at 12pm we'll
see y'all next time peace peace